hey guys my name is just and it is
Friday which means I've got five of this
week's best stories and gaming to get
you all caught up on what's been going
on metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain
may have proved itself to be a 10 out of
10 game but its servers have had some
trouble during launch week as of
yesterday service for all five of the
game platforms were down and undergoing
maintenance connection issues have been
reported by gamers since the phantom
pain launched on Tuesday and they've
been specifically affecting the Forward
Operating Base multiplayer mode you can
get the most up-to-date info on whether
or not the servers are online by heading
to konami japanese website or by
attempting and failing to log in to the
servers our works too despite the fact
that battlefield 4 is almost two years
old of the game just received a massive
deal CPAC and a brand new patch on
Tuesday dice released the free DLC packs
call tonight operations which introduces
a new map called savad graveyard shift
based on existing bubble fields warm up
is the vaad 311 graveyard shift will
supposedly allow me to get your stuff on
much more than the original map and it
will support a bunch of battlefield 4
modes including conquest rush and team
deathmatch also released this week was
battlefield fours massive summer patch
which includes a whole lot of tweaks and
changes to the game's weapons naps modes
and so on you can check out the full
list of features and changes on gamespot
those of us came for the Deadpool movie
we'll have to wait until next year but
Activision have announced that they're
releasing the Deadpool game for current
consoles the news was first revealed by
a tweet from gamestop early this week
the retailer revealed that the 2013
action game is getting the HD remake
treatment and will be arriving on Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 on November 17
should you want to pick it up the game
will run you 50 bucks gamespot gave the
original release a five point five out
of 10 criticizing its poor camera and
control issues in combat despite its
great references and chokes more news
about the street fighter 5 roster landed
this week and now we know that three
brand new characters are on their way
the game will have 16 characters at
launch eight will be series regulars
like ryu and chun li or a lesser-known
returning characters including rainbow
maker and nash and the final floor will
be brand new they're only one of these
new characters we've seen so far is the
big head slashing fighter McCauley the
next three are going to be announced in
the months leading up to Street Fighter
5 s launched in march of next year
street fighter brand director matt
Dahlgren explained the roster discussion
is probably the most intense one
internally before the game comes out
adding that they consulted experts and
conducted a fan poll to see what
characters people wanted to see in the
game Capcom are also planning to add
characters post-launch
this week Naughty Dog announced that
uncharted 4 is going to be getting
single-player deal see for the first
time in the franchise naughty dogs are
Maya explained the move by looking at
the success of left behind the
single-player DLC for the last of us he
said it worked really well for us for
the last of us we thought that we could
put together a really great piece of
content as well for uncharted 4 Maya
added that the studio have wanted to
make single-player DLC for uncharted for
a while but couldn't envision a way to
make it work for the action-adventure
series until now uncharted 4 is drew out
in March of 2016 for ps4 let me know
down in that comment box what kind of
single-player DLC you'd like to see
Naughty Dog pull out of the bag for
uncharted this week on site I give you a
bunch of tips for playing Mad Max Lucy
give you a dragon age inquisition
refresher on in two minutes and GameSpot
reviews a Super Mario maker that is
everything I got for you this week be
sure to let me know what you've been
playing and what you cared about in the
news be sure to have yourselves a good
weekend